(applause)
- Speaking of the original
cast of "First Wives Club",
I hear you ran into Goldie
Hawn, which is awesome.
- [Male Guest] What?
- I would've just started saying
lines from "Bird on a Wire"
like all the films from my childhood.
- She doesn't do well
with meeting icons though.
- I don't either.
I don't know if you've noticed.
(laughing)
- Girl, it was a good thing
we weren't there together.
First of all, it's
embarrassing because I was
at the psychic's.
- You were at a psychic?
- A psychic, not the side-kick.
I was at the psychic.
'Cause I was like just
tell me that everything
is gonna work out in my life, you know.
And I guess Goldie wanted
to know if everything
was gonna work out in her life.
And it was right when
Kate had had the next,
her third baby, the little girl.
And all I could think,
the door opened,
and there she was,
and I was like,
I know my psychic isn't Goldie Hawn.
You know what I mean?
For a minute, I was like, maybe it is.
- Wouldn't that be amazing?
- I mean so amazing.
Like that's where my
mind, our brain right?
- Exactly.
- And then I just, I realized
she wasn't the psychic.
And then I was like,
oh my God, congratulations
on your baby girl!
(male laughing)
- What did she do?
- She did this.
She was like, thank you.
- That's kinda how I feel
Meryl got scared of me.
I was loud, though.
She should've been scared.
I was excited.